and now Tim Dylan is going to have
[Music]
3 a.m. 4 in California we were sitting
upstairs at Ben's house and we're
talking about drugs and we were saying I
was saying we should go record some of
this cuz it's gold whether it is or not
we were just talking about you know cuz
I did some drugs I know some you don't
believe that people get angry some
people send me comments I read it or
whatever a screenshot he made up that he
did drugs to make himself seem dark it's
like hey number one
it wasn't all that dark it had dark
elements there's a lot of fun
I'm the Hemingway uh and also doing
drugs you're doing like doing a lot of
blow at 13s not and like uncommon thing
I mean it's not you know the typical
behavior of a thirteen year old but it's
also not like an unheard of thing people
are like having kids at 14 P living
children have 14 years old you think
it's so unbelievable and you think
that's what I invented by the way you
know like I invented the fact that I did
blow at 13 to just give myself some
depth cuz [ __ ] every because there's
nothing else there's nothing else in my
life that could have give made me
interesting by the way I had to say oh
and by the way 13 I did a bump of coke
in my friends backyard so uh you know I
get it whatever everyone else is going
through out there I get it you know like
I never talk about addiction I never
really talk about recovery who cares
and I don't because I know when I
inevitably relapse and I'm on this
podcast barely able to speak it's gonna
be real
real try not to laugh in the mic Ben
people hate your laugh I had a second
complain about it
you have now two complaints I saw three
positive comments about my life ten tens
of thousands of people listened to the
show two to three of them want to kill
you because your laugh that's where
they're at in their life there they want
to murder you
cuz the sound of joy leaving your body
just [ __ ] rubs them the wrong way but
like it's just funny to me that like
that's the thing say I'm not gay
Sam pretending to be gay it's much
funnier and a better argument than like
oh he's pretending to do just look at me
I clearly did drugs at some point in my
life listen to my voice what do you
think was going on I wish it in I don't
it's not like a mark of pride that's
what these idiots don't realize they
think it's saying I think it was cool no
I think it was cool to be a brilliant
athlete and get a scholarship and and
and do good thing like that would have
been cool what I did was like fine fine
it was a fine way to live it was not
uncommon being a drug addict foreclosing
on a house in Long Island this does not
make me special at all maybe in your
town maybe where you grew up this makes
you maybe you think it's like a big deal
nobody would even understand the long I
know what you meant if you like yeah
that guy like made up that he was a coke
head when he was a teenager and then
bought a hat like Emma Blake what yeah
he wanted to seem different so he made
up that he was a coke Adney went
bankrupt everyone a bit different
what no if I wanted to be different
where I came from I would have made up a
college
that I attended that's what I would have
done you sleuths you read it sleuths out
there but Rotella been there was a
pizzeria in my town and sold coke this
is how fat and sad my town was dad a
pizzeria got busted for selling cocaine
not a bar not a club a pizzeria and this
is true it's all in the news it's all
verifiable we could post them articles
you can look it up you know he's making
it up
he made that thing about a pizzeria
selling coke in his jail because he
wanted to seem dark yeah that's what I'm
doing
brilliant and I have so many shows right
all this drug stuff I fabricated that's
why I have all these shows in
development now Mike the movie about my
life's coming out it all worked it all
worked it's coming out this summer
hmm it was a they used to people used to
call this place an order the slang for
cocaine was a white pie which was pretty
standard
nobody really ordered white pies ever I
mean I'm sure that they were a thing
they are good a white pie is just cheese
and when I grew up no one ever [ __ ]
with that
go over somebody's house at a pizza that
maybe pepperoni
you know the the gourmet pizza thing
came in later where you would just you
know throw anything on a pizza you know
you put shaved black truffles on Pete
that wasn't my upbringing sadly but it
was a Pete you just pizza that was it or
cocaine that was the other option you
could get pizza or you could get cocaine
and people would come in and people just
order white pie and bet ask me Ben was
like do they go through the then they go
through the trouble of putting like a
eight ball of coke which isn't which is
look at what an eight ball Ben is I
forget is it two and a half grams it may
be more than that man I haven't done an
eight ball in a while and I mean like
seven or eight years I don't mean a
while like you know a few days I mean
I'm 3.5 grams 3.5 grams of cocaine that
would be a white pie eight ball and Ben
was like did they put it in a pizza box
I don't know but I do know that me and
my friend when we ordered drugs from
that Petri we also wanted a pizza which
a lot of other people did it I'm not
even kidding this is not a joke I wish
it was we would order we'd order
we also wanted food we like hold on why
don't you stay on the line they're like
yeah we'll be there in a few minutes
it's like no no no relax you're not
gonna be in a few minutes you need to
make some stuffed shells first this
isn't [ __ ] kurt metzger likes you
laughs - [ __ ] these people but we would
order weed and we'd get bags of weed on
top of a BBQ chicken pizza
the
best barbecue chicken pizza sucks now it
just sucks people don't understand what
it should be when a barbecue chicken
pizza should be as a regular pizza with
red sauce and cheese and you should take
chicken cutlets that are breaded and
chop them up in a bowl with open pit
barbecue sauce which is a lot of people
do not like this barbecue sauce because
it's very strong tasting it has a
metallic taste it's a it's a reddish
brown color if you cook it it gets even
darker like dried blood and they serve
it with steak tidbits in Long Island and
if you take it you don't heat it up you
don't cook it you take the open pit and
you toss the breaded cutlets that you've
chopped up in the barbecue sauce and you
just put it on top of the pizza um and
the cutlets are cooked they're warm it's
whatever that is the best and maybe
throw a little cheese on top of that if
you want but that is the best kind of
barbecue chicken pho just sloppy
disgusting white trash and my friend's
mother was lactose intolerant and she
had something called lactate and we used
to drink it we used to call it tade he's
gonna get some tade it's disgusting
tasted like like gelatin I don't know
what it was wasn't milk lactate now is I
think better tasting but it wasn't
really in the late 90s it was rough and
we would eat barbecue chicken pizza and
lactaid and I remember his mother walked
into the kitchen one day this woman was
great
this woman was named barb I'm not gonna
tell you her last name but you'd go
hello boys hello boys and she always had
Barbara red
hanging out of her mouth her and her
husband was sitting these lazy boy
recliner and they would just smoke and
watch the tube and drink a little
sangria or maybe a little wine on a
holiday or a special occasion weekends
would be a little sangria to make a
batch of sangria and she was [ __ ]
hilarious when I remember one day she
walked into the kitchen and we're eating
barbecue chicken pizza and drinking
lactaid and she just looked at us and
she went hello boys she goes you know
you boys a disgusting two chubby kids
eating pizza drinking lactaid and I
don't even think we looked at her I
think we just kept eating I don't even
think we look here he had an older
brother who's a cop and I was like 18
shame guy who was disgusted by us he
wouldn't even look at us he hated his
brother and he hated me anyway always
say things like his brother had a room
in the basement and his older brother
big what are you two guys doing [ __ ]
each other down there we weren't there
was a fun thing to say and like and and
his his mother when I was back enough of
that is it what are they doing done
they're [ __ ] each other
she'd be like language and we wouldn't
even we just keep eating you know it's
good barbecue chicken pizza when you
just keep going people could say
whatever they want about you
but I'll tell you it's funny when I
think about like that time you hear
different stories about how like people
grow up you know like we have a you know
now it's like you know everybody now is
like it's nicer now it's a nicer too
nicer world I guess I mean I I'm sure it
is
people are kinder gentler they try to be
I don't know that that I think in some
cases that's great
you know it ain't funny I'll tell you
that much cuz we would get brutalized
but it was very funny when you look back
on some of the things people would just
say to you it was she wasn't even mad
when she was like you boys are
discussing she was just making an
observation that was accurate and it was
just really really funny
and you can't I had another friend whose
mother was like a high-priced call girl
at one time and I'm talking like what
I'm this is when I'm in junior high and
her mom was a sexual woman an older
woman but a sexual woman like she
me and my friend once we were standing
in her kitchen and I think a girl in our
grade had just gotten pregnant it was
kind of like a big deal and the mother
came up to the mother of like three
names like different names throughout
her life but they all ended with an i
one was Tony one was brandy and one was
Tony and they still and ended with a tie
and like people knew his different names
throughout her life it's one of my
favorite people to this day I I what she
drove me and her daughter when we were
in eighth grade to a head shop to buy
bongs and she drove us there hammered
and she was drinking in the car and she
was chugging I forget what is the thing
that taste was I don't think it was
Jager but she was just chugging what's
the thing that's like taste like
medicine almost was it black house
what's black house I could be totally
wrong here but
slicker maybe it was that is it the
purple label I think it was I can't be
sure
yeah I think it might have been I don't
know what it was was something that her
daughter liked tastes like blackberry
and she she drove us to the head shop
we're in eighth grade droves to the head
shop to buy nice bar her daughter got a
beautiful glass bong and and and she was
drinking black house and she looked at
me and she looked at her daughter and
she saw we had all this weed and she
goes we're gonna have a good night on
earth tonight I swear to God and this
was a great she's a great woman this was
a good woman
now this is I guess you know too many
people listening they would disagree
with that and they would have maybe an
argument sure um
but I remember after this we found out
Scott got pregnant me and my friend Shay
we're standing in this woman's kitchen
and she said you know what you do you
know how you can avoid this and we
weren't even we would do nothing we
eaten barbecue chicken pizza we're not
[ __ ] anyone we're not getting hand
jobs nothing was going on no two people
needed that talk less than me in this
kid I was just a sexually confused
foodie and then this kid wasn't really
[ __ ] anyone either
so nobody neat that we weren't like
virile like strapping young guys that
were like you know hiring a [ __ ]
brood of children she came up to us we
you gotta remember in eighth grade they
came up to us and she goes you know what
you do when people ask if you [ __ ]
that's what she said cuz people ask if
you're having sex if you're [ __ ] you
tell him no you say I [ __ ] myself you
say I treat myself real good
she was like in front of us right in our
face she goes you say I treat myself
real good I masturbate and I have sex
and me and him were like just so stoned
and this was maybe the funniest thing
that had ever happened in our lives that
this woman who was clearly should the
energy of a madam like every madam
that's ever been portrayed in in any in
any popular culture it's this woman and
she was like you tell him you treat
yourself real good I remember standing
there with him and then she left the
room and we collapsed on the floor
laughing so hard and then there was a
guy who lived downstairs named Uncle
Rick and he had no tongue
he had a half a tongue talk but this and
he don't look Tony
like yet half a ton I don't know why
cancer it a problem something to happen
and he we're laughing her on his kitchen
floor he opens his door and he goes turn
off the [ __ ] floor and we were now
crying crying laughing he's like your
birth fat [ __ ]
get off the floor and we just stumbled
out of the house crying tears streaming
down our face I think I left my jacket
there it was like [ __ ] December it's
cold and I mean
not six months later we do
acid at this woman's house we tell her
she knows real doing acid and we loved
hanging out in the house
we loved it me and my friend we never
wanted to leave every but like her
daughter wanted to leave because she
lived there so like a bunch of kids
would come over the house we do all
kinds of drugs and then the daughter
would leave with the kids and like go to
the park or go walk around and go meet
other people me and my friend we're like
no we'll hang at the house we thought it
was a little resort was on the water
like a bigger house it's just nice we
just liked being in the house so what
happened was the daughter and some of
our other friend go to trip acid they're
like we want to be in nature we want to
go to the park we want to Mable go to
the beach be my friend who like no
thanks we'll just hang out Lisa's room
and the mother opens the door as we're
tripping and she comes in and she starts
dancing and she goes do the funky like
she was doing the funky chicken dance
and she was kind of talking like Uncle
Rick for whatever reason she's a through
the front through the front and we just
stared at her and then she looked at us
and she went now you'll never know if
that really happened or not and she just
shut the door
this woman was a great woman one time a
guy ripped her daughter off for drugs
and she just started calling every drug
dealer in town and telling them that
this guy was a rat and he was working
for the police I remember that she
called every single person's because I
just want to let you know that
Jonathan's working for the police
Jonathan's a rat he's working for the
police do with that information what you
want I mean she got out of a car once
and accosted this guy
my friends a lesbian this this girl and
her one of her shows dated strippers
like hot strippers it were kind of crazy
and then one one of those strippers was
at the house once and apparently her
mother walked outside just moisture.you
like mush someone's face you know when
you take your hand and mush their faith
so she must her stripper girlfriends
face in the car and you know me and my
friend we're always there always there
just to chubby kids in every drama every
family problem what was just standing
there you know she's there and up the
stripper walks in and she's like you
Tony mushed me she just mushed me and we
went in there and Tony go Tony looked at
her daughter goes I don't know what
she's talking about I think she's sick I
think she's very sick and then we went
in Tony's room and Tony goes she gave us
give us a Viking in each and she goes
and then she showed us each house she
mushed her she showed us each house she
did it we were so happy we took a little
Viking it was sitting there and she cuz
I just went up to her and I mustered a
face Tony so glad to see your face and
we just laughed and these are these are
the this is what I feel like you don't
have with the opioid crisis you don't
have these fun stories you have a lot of
problems now have a lot of issues a lot
of issues out there it's not nearly as
fun now drugs were not always fun they
ended poorly for me as as as many others
you know I have no credit so that's one
of those reasons when you pull my credit
score up you get a blank piece of paper
you know I have no I have no like I
don't exist on paper in this world I'm
doing okay on Instagram but I don't
really I don't exist
everything I've done credit Wise has
been so horrific I've had a car
repossessed a house foreclosed
I remember this is how poor people stay
poor I got a credit card once golden key
credit which is like the shittiest
credit card I think the limit was too
d the activation fee was 230 so I
activated this card and then I go try to
pay for a dinner and it wouldn't even go
through it was a cheap dinner and it
wouldn't even go through this was years
and years ago but it just goes to show
you how [ __ ] activation feels like to
honge 250 maybe and there was no limit
on the car and then you could of course
call it try to increase it just to just
to stay [ __ ] stay [ __ ] get [ __ ] and
stay [ __ ] cheap predatory credit folks
today's episode here brought to you by
Wix we've talked about Wix before you
know we're gonna talk about it again Wix
is just a place where you can make a
[ __ ] website ok you lazy piece of
[ __ ] you can start from scratch or
choose over 500 stunning templates which
says the most innovative drag-and-drop
website builder so you can easily
customize your site add text images
videos whatever you want you can even
use their artificial design intelligence
you can use robot to design your website
if you do not personally want to design
your website for your business or
whatever the [ __ ] you can use a robot ok
isn't that nice
go to Tim Dylan's going to hell calm Dee
I ll ons going to hell calm no is OK go
to the bottom click on the link you'll
save money 10% off any Wix premium plan
you'll love it it's great ok that's the
move here folks everybody needs a
website doesn't matter if you're your 3
weeks the doctors giving you a few
months to live you know you have an
inoperable tumor get on the site put it
out there do a photo yourself every day
as you decline you know its Wix folks
it's the spot you got to do it it's
gonna be fun you ever built the website
god it's fun to build a website you know
have some fun in your life ok
[Applause]
promising folks from essent he's a [ __ ]
spray you spray it on your [ __ ] you last
longer in bed a lot of men are not
pleasuring the
partners that's unfortunate men come in
five and a half minutes takes women 18
minutes per mess it was developed by the
best doctors in the world they're the
greatest doctors that have ever lived
the most capable minds in medicine have
designed this [ __ ] spray for you okay I
love it I spray it on my [ __ ] not even
to have sex I just like to have a hard
[ __ ] I wake up I look at it and then I
go right back to bed it's recommended by
over 2200 urologist as a first-line
defense to last longer in bed it is the
number one sexual enhancer product on
Amazon it's the only delay spray in
North America with clinical studies to
back up its effectiveness it's just not
testimonials from losers it's literal
clinical studies I don't know how they
did them but it's funny to think about
you don't need a prescription there's no
awkward doctor visit you go to delay
spray calm de la y SP RA Y dot-com -
they spray calm use the promo code Tim
15 you'll get 15% off your purchase okay
delay sprayed calm this is really the
move everybody here uses it everybody is
walking around here with hard [ __ ]
it's absolutely the best you guys are
gonna love it boom boom boom it's gonna
be great I'm telling you if you're in a
bad relationship it's probably because
you have a soft [ __ ] not good but your
drugs didn't end well but there was a
lot up like there were some really funny
people back then you know there were
some really and this woman had an impact
on me she was a real character she was a
genuine genuine character and you know
like that was a house you go if you need
a weed house she'd go off you needed a
couple of I keys she's still there where
she no she's still there you know I
think they're by mean they're probably
real today I think they're they're very
tame now like there's nothing going on
her daughter doesn't live there anymore
like it's not it was a party house it's
not a party house
I mean her other daughter who I know her
other daughter dated a guy who ended up
dying of an overdose
good dude great dude this guy Connor
really great [ __ ] guy who [ __ ]
died sadly and I knew his little brother
I knew his mom Mike I knew their whole
[ __ ] family and it was dad and I
still do and the great kids great people
but who's tough me it was like that was
a but but you know they were a wild
family they were wild like everybody's
got a family like that everybody's got a
wife unless you're a total [ __ ] [ __ ]
like you know every single person that
writes for a show and if have had no
valuable immediate experiences in their
life other than writing some half-baked
[ __ ] for the Harvard Lampoon that nine
people can understand and even they're
not laughing at it so I mean I mean but
other than that everybody has it really
has a crazy fan to you did you have a
crazy cuz I have a few I have a few
crazy families did you have a crazy
family in in Texas and yeah and Tuscola
I mean it was a lot of you know math and
just like good old boys who would pull
guns on each other that would still deer
feed from each other and like
legitimately pulled steel deer feed just
deer corn there was this one guy audio a
white trash Jesus Christ can't even tell
a story without just putting it all they
would steal deer feed from each other
they pull guns there's this kid named
cactus yeah leaked birth name perfect
when it was okay his real name is I
can't say it it's so funny though [ __ ]
his that his last name is a liquor brick
liquor brand why can't you say it well I
guess I can he's passed away now but his
name of course you can say him you dumb
[ __ ] his name was Cactus Jack Daniels
swear to God
really swear to God when you name a kid
that that is it that's a death sentence
that kid is dead Cactus Jack Daniel's
house
Cactus Jack doin um well he just
graduated Northeastern and he's got his
own veterinary practice no you know how
he's doing he's dead
how did you know this kid I went to
school with them and I mean one day
there was this kid named I think his
name was like Easton and he [ __ ]
names
he stole a bag of deer feed why out of
cactuses truck just to [ __ ] with him how
old are these kids Oh 16 I mean a lot of
kids got sent home cuz the sheriff would
go through the parking lot and find
shotguns and rifles in their car and
they'd be like hey you got it you can't
have they're like well I'm going hunting
after school right yeah but you can't
have eight gun now the kids go I'm going
hunting in school so that the sheriff
would send them home yeah yeah I
remember cactus cactus went and pulled a
gun pulled the 22 on East he drove to
his house and he was taking the deer
feet out of the back out of the truck
bed and putting it his and yeah it was
east and walked out of the house and
pulled a gun on him he's like you better
put that [ __ ] bag deer corn backward
belong because my and they had they
pulled guns on each other and then just
went their separate ways I mean this is
like how did cactus pass away um he had
a weird thing in his head you know when
people have like Britt is it a brain
hemorrhage aneurysm yeah yeah that he
had that he just like he just died 24 ah
kid sweet kid I love that guy he's a
nice guy
r.i.p I keep thinking a Captain Jack
that's the Long Island version yeah
Captain Jack man Texas is a different
kind of crazy mm-hmm you know we didn't
have any good like nobody I knew had a
gun I think some of the kids dad's had
guns some of the kids dads were like mob
guys cuz the town that I lived in was a
town where dudes were in there were
connected guys but when I was growing up
it was the tail end of that at least
tail end of like organized
I mean it was just like Street guys that
were just they were somebody's cousin
and they would you know like the town
that I grew up and this is true Tony
Soprano was based off a guy that lived
in my town who ran a family in New
Jersey the de Cavalcanti family and a
lot of the episode ideas come right out
of Rico transcripts that her friend that
guy was like taking out FBI showed up to
his house it was like a thing you know I
showed you the house
yeah yeah right down the street from
where you grew up right there yeah my
mom like told his kids had a swim and
then there were other like all the like
a few of the kenri Hill lived in the
town I grew up in Goodfellas and Paulie
from that movie living it I mean my
family had no real dealings but my
grandmother was a schoolteacher my
mother taught people how to swim my dad
was like a musician so he would just
play music at bars and then you know he
was in office he sold off his equipment
or whatever he thought he did and but
not we weren't like intimately involved
but like my dad when he got to the town
was like a tough town when I was growing
up it was not that it but it was still
it was still that it was still kind of
in the air even though it was over you
know it was over in like a substantive
way but it was still there like it was
like the town I grew up in had a lot of
bars the nightlife was big and the bar
business in that town was huge is there
like any Italian mob laughs yeah sure
but they're not I mean they're not a
factor in the way that like the Russians
are or even like ms-13 things like that
you know I don't think I think you know
the law stick can't by judges anymore
they don't have the political clout they
don't have they just can't
everybody rats now everybody kind of
just says what they do there nobody gets
killed they all just go and open up a
strip club in Arizona or Vegas or
something then they're they're kind of
okay they only leave the witness
protection program that's okay the right
books they go on TV they do
Podcast other there on twitch we know
what's killing them you know they're on
tick-tock dancing they're fine there's
no more threat that like you'll be
ostracized and you'll be a rats like
everyone's a rat you can't go to
somebody anymore like you'd quit your
grandfather's a rat it's like yeah well
he's on tick tock he's got 800 views
dancing the little NAS acts you go
alright
yeah he's cool hey but I mean that was
like and the town's called Island Park
you can look all this up by the way
before you go I you know accuse me he
made up all this stuff he said he was in
the Mafia when he was a kid because no
one listens they listen every eighth
word and then it concoct what I said he
said he took Evan McGuinness he was in
the Mafia um but it was a it was a weird
it was a lot of drugs there were a lot
of drugs around you know the girl who
lived across the street from me
her brother sold acid and she took like
a half a sheet of it
and then cut off half of her hair with a
kitchen knife and she was a problem you
know she was a little loopy um she had
some issues after that she had some
issues I'll be very honest she was you
know eccentric but you could get you
know everybody smoked weed everybody
you know pretty much did any
hallucinogen he can get your hands on
whether it's acid shrooms Special K you
know the ketamine I think it's a cat
tranquilizer I forget I think he's a cat
tranquilizer
you could look that up you go in a
k-hole if you took too much of it we had
there was this one guy he would take way
too much and then just sit there and
stare he's a cat tranquilizer I'm wrong
you could be wrong on that I always
thought it was a horse drink it my wife
yeah I don't know
and then I people do not Molly they
would just add just ecstasy and back in
those days I sound like a Boomer back in
those days the ecstasy tablets had
Mitsubishi logos and some of them would
have logos of other things from pop
culture um and it was a good time it was
a great way to grow up it was a great
way to grow up doing drugs with crazy
people now he did not prepare you for
life that is the flip side the flip side
of that is there were not a lot of
college tours like you know I heard like
Greg Fitzsimmons was taking his son to
all these colleges it's like a nice
thing to do that didn't happen with a
lot of my friends their parents weren't
touring colleges with them some were but
a lot of the people I knew that was not
it you know they weren't going on a
college tour with pop you know it didn't
you know that was never even thought of
in my family like that my dad would go
and drive me to a bunch of nice liberal
arts schools in the Northeast you know
talk about my dad always said my biggest
regret was not finishing college but
then he also never told me to really go
to college like you should go to school
you know but not you know he was like
he's like my biggest regret was not
going to college
almost he almost
like and he knew that would be also my
biggest regret he's like in this family
our biggest regret is that we don't go
to college son he told me once I said
why don't we go to camp why don't I go
to camp and he goes we're not Jewish
which meant I don't have money I'm a
manager of colortile that's why you're
not going to camp now go to that school
recreation program with all these other
degenerate brittle boned you know Jolly
Rancher eating future cocaine addicts
and that makes them lifelong friends at
the school that's a great way it's a
great way for your kids to be drug
addicts by the time they're 15 send them
to a school recreation program in the
summer with everyone else who's too poor
to afford to go to sleepaway camp those
kids will really figure it out together
huh that's a great group she's everybody
from detention in summer school yeah we
go to the shitty program and like the
bus drivers every bus driver in my town
was a morbidly obese woman and kind of
[ __ ] like there was this one named
Ronnie there's one lady named miss
Donnelly she headed us would you guys
[ __ ] with her would you guys he got [ __ ]
down that's what she said that was her
whole job [ __ ] out and she hated us cuz
we'd knock on a door hi cuz she lived on
our block and we'd knock on a door and
we'd be like can we use the phone and
she'd be like get out of here oh we got
one time we knocked on the door were
like do you have the time and she's like
it's 4:30 get out of here she lived on
my block we thought it was hilarious
where was I
it's just funny to us to knock on her
door she hated us it was Ronnie Ronnie
was kind of Ronnie would let me out they
weren't supposed to let you out during
lunch recess and Ronnie would let me out
because she was gone she was
and I'd go Ronnie there's a fire and she
would open the door and she would never
get excited to scream I go Ronnie to the
fire we gotta go she know okay then open
of doing any to walk over to her and be
like Ronnie you can't let him out it
should be like he said there was a fire
big Ronnie there is no fire I don't know
why they put her on the door I don't
know why they put this woman on the door
I got suspended once and there's I put
it on Instagram for being swear to God
quotes timmy was given a day of
in-school suspension for being and I
quote rude and inappropriately demanding
of the staff in the lunchroom because
these these lunch shades by the way
we're like they wanted to be teachers
many of them but many of them like for
whatever reason couldn't they couldn't
be teachers so they were lunch shades
and I'm not [ __ ] on lunches but I
will say I will say I will say this this
is maybe controversial tank these are
not the brightest people on the planet
in most cases there's a I'm sure there's
a brilliant lunch and I'm not by the way
this isn't a comment on their value as
people but they're not they're they're
they were in many cases frustratingly
stupid even as a child I would be like
why are you this dumb how are you this a
offensively stupid and I was a [ __ ] of a
kid I'm never trying to exonerate myself
in any of these stories and like we had
frozen yogurt in the lunchroom I don't
know why but we had frozen yogurt at one
time and you get these little you know
the little cups that they test yogurt
with now like you get a little taster
cop or they hand out pills and mental
institutions like where my mother lives
they have these little cups and they
fill them with sprinkles you only got
like to sprinkle cups per thing and I
was kind of like that's I don't that
isn't that isn't working so I took a
bunch more and the woman who was like
this Czechoslovakian woman instead of
just yelling at me started crying
that I took more sprinkles and I should
have she started bawling and and wailing
like like like someone had slick sold
her gypsy daughter into sex slavery like
she was whaling like and she's crying
and then all the other lunch shades ran
over to her they brought me to the Dean
they said they were the principal at
that point they were like he made her
cry he starts screaming at me and I was
just staring at all these people like
what are you doing
what is your life what is your life I
don't understand why is she crying that
I took extra sprinkles and why have you
people tolerated this instead of hitting
her and then me the the only move there
was to beat both of us that was the only
logical thing to do but instead you've
rushed me to the principal's office and
that poor guys probably trying to I
don't know [ __ ] a student in there and
you interrupted him and now he's got to
lecture me on fairness or whatever so
this is you know again don't yes
if you're gonna invest in your kids send
them to a real school send them to a
real summer program don't send them to a
program where they're gonna meet the
future people who are gonna OD in their
house get a real get a real thing going
better help better help don't kill
yourself don't do it don't kill yourself
cause of better help go to better help
calm slash Tim Dylan 10% off your first
month what is it
it is a organization that is offering
licensed professional counselors who
specialize in issues like depression
stress anxiety relationships sleeping
anger family conflict self-esteem and
more better help lets you connect with
your professional accounts learn it's
safe and private online environment
anything you share is confidential okay
they don't tweet it out
they don't livestream the sessions
they're here to help you and you don't
even have to leave your [ __ ] house
apartment shed van under the bridge
wherever you are you don't have to leave
if you're not happy with your therapist
you can request a new one at any time at
no additional charge it's not a big deal
okay you don't have to look them in the
face it's great many of you don't like
that anyway that's why you're [ __ ] in
the position that you're in
so better help calm slash Tim Dylan I
mean but a lot of my friends made it out
a lot of them are dead some of them went
to jail some of them went to jail and
they cleaned it up some of them liked me
financially ruined them
their lives but a lot of my feel like my
close friend is fine the kid that I used
to hang out and eat barbecue chicken
pizza with he's doing great um but we
would just we I was the guy that like
even though I've had groups of friends I
tend to have one or two close friends
and then we kind of make our way through
different groups like we never I was
never the guy like I've been in groups
but I always was kind of a guy that had
like a partner or a few close friends
and you would kind of go out and do [ __ ]
with them you'd go to places
and I think part of that was and I
didn't play sports oh it was on a team
so you didn't have a bunch of kid like I
was on swim team that's not a team you
know but the sports kids always had a
huge clique of people you know even in
high school when I was quote-unquote
popular kid I was like you know
nominated for homecoming king and I hung
out with all the jock kids even in that
group I had a little smaller group of
people I think everybody does at a
certain point but um you know so me and
my friend would just we would go out and
get in trouble we just go out and make
friends you can kind of make friends if
you don't have a large group you can you
can assimilate into other groups so if
you go with six people it's harder for
you know these Hector and Sonya these
two people that are in their 20s you're
14 they're in their 20s you can't jump
in their car and go to the Bronx to get
coke if you would six people but if it's
just you and your friend who are in size
three people but you can still fit in
the back of a car with Hector and Sonya
and you can take a nice little drive to
the Bronx to get some weed and some
cocaine and just drive around and have
some fun and that's what we did that was
what we did that was eighth grade oh
you're handing me more cigarettes yeah
that's sweet these are the stale ones
you know it's you know so funny go on
Google there are people that Google can
I get six smoking stale cigarettes isn't
that good
isn't that know they're the healthy ones
they're the good ones it's it's amazing
but that's kind of when I when I
remember that stuff I remember it as fun
but it was also a lot of you know
getting caught coming home at 2:00 or
3:00 a.m. being terrified our parents
being home or being up they were always
home I would say I was sleeping at this
kid
she was sleeping in my house we'd spend
an entire night going out with crazy
people and then we'd have to come home
and tiptoe in his house at [ __ ] 2:45
and I remember one time like we always
there was a part of my town where ruse a
block away from his house but as soon as
you turned the corner you could see his
house and every time we came home for
the most part the lights were dark and
then one night we coming down of coke
which is a worst feeling in the world
you know and we turn the corner and the
lights are on and we froze like a stone
use it 2:45 in the morning there was no
reason that the lights in his house
should be on and I mean all of them not
a nightlight not a kitchen light the
living the lights are on so we looked
and he looked at me and I remember that
it goes were [ __ ] we're [ __ ] right
now I looked at him and I said yeah here
we are
he goes we're just gonna say we were
walking around that was always our go-to
we will clearly drug addicts people were
missing money school was suspending us
we were hanging out with the bad kids
everybody knew everybody know there are
people out there that are a mess in
their life and they think they're
fooling everyone you're fooling no one
and when you go back and talk to those
people say now I brought Ben to one of
my friends houses in Long Island when I
was in the mortgage industry and he was
again Tim would show up in different
cars he disappeared for two or three
days show back up look looking crazy
you're not no one's fooled everybody
knows what you're doing they might not
want to believe it but they know down
deep that you're a [ __ ] degenerate so
we go to his house we walk up and them
and we said we go we're just gonna say
we're walking around we not gonna door
barb barb answers Barb's got a Barbie
red hanging out of her mouth she goes
hello boys like [ __ ] she goes you know I
was on the phone with patty Dylan patty
thinks we should call the police so let
me call her back and let you know that
you boys are home and then Tim I think
it's best if you go to your house they
didn't even ask where we were and at
that point me and my friend Shea look at
her
we were walking around and she goes cuz
they all know that you're doing
something bad and then I went back to my
house and my mother was pissed and she's
like well you I should take you to the
hospital what are you on look at your
eyes are you gonna die fun ah you know
so there were those moments there were
those moments there were those moments I
got to be
honest I would not trade any of my
friend Tina's mother telling us to
masturbate and treat ourselves well you
call you treat yourself you tell them
you treat yourself well good you cheat
and that guy with no tongue running up a
girl got off before I wouldn't trade
that for any of the horrific laying in
the bed sweating coming down of cocaine
feeling disgusting masturbating
furiously and it gross coke sweat
totally gross
and then my mother when my mother and
father got divorced and this was really
one of the craziest times in my life one
like my mother goes okay I'm keeping the
house in Long Island your father moved
out eighth grade and she goes I'm gonna
rent rooms to keep the house well
spoiler alert who rents the rooms in the
house young Asian students studying at
NYU no know who rents the rooms people
in construction people that are have no
jobs and my house there were three rooms
three rooms rented all to drug dealers
slash people that would connect you with
other dealer like it was a drug house my
eighth grade house was a drug house my
and and it was and a carrot in the ninth
grade ninth grade I was living with my
dad and I would visit my house but
eighth grade I was I was living there
staying between there my grandmother's
house and three rooms were rented out to
two people that were on that were
druggies and and you would it was crazy
and
was so convenient you know if you ever
have a drug problem and three drug
dealers move into your house you know
you're set
you really are set it's a I mean meet me
in the kitchen
really really you have a graham and
you're in my kitchen great and we [ __ ]
me and my friend Shay we just hang out
and and do drugs these people and then
this woman Michelle move then man how
many Michelle's have I known that her
crazy this lady Michelle a great person
now a felon you know you know you know
well you know woman who you know but and
I don't mean a great person in a
biblical sense but you know she always
had some cocaine for us eighth grade
doing blow with us and
she moved into my house because one of
the guys at the pizzeria who grew up
with my mother goes she needs a room
this woman needs a room she's uh she'll
move in so she moved in and me and my
friend started to blow with her
immediately and she would drive us
around in her Lincoln old Lincoln town
click an old Lincoln and she had kids
and she was pregnant so she had to stop
doing blow when she was pregnant but she
would still get us the blow and we would
hang out with her and at one time when
the kid it was like she was like nine
months pregnant we did blow with her and
she goes the baby's already formed so
it's okay I think that was literally
what she said and looking back now I
realized that that is a disturbing image
to some people to fat kids to him blow
with a fully pregnant woman a fully
pregnant woman in my house doing cocaine
at my dining room table with a fully
pregnant lady but then at that moment it
seemed okay it seemed it seemed fine and
that was a water that was the time in my
life where I could have gone off the
rails even worse than I did and I
somehow and they they got me out of
there they're like you got to get out of
here this is not good for you
I mean I remember one guy walked into my
house Austria and my friend was sleeping
over he walked in and he gave us acid
and we took acid at 3:00 in the morning
and it we're rolling when like
everyone's getting up for work we're
just rolling on acid
my mother was screaming what is wrong
with you she's like I hate these drug
addicts and alcoholics screaming and her
friend Dennis who died Dennis was a
great guy Dennis was an older guy served
in Vietnam had a bad divorce with his
wife instead of giving her any money he
decided to live in a van by the beach
interesting man drank wine out of a
Burger King plastic cop would walk
around the house and all he would say is
life in the big city so no matter what
the news was he'd go life in the big
city like my mother would say you know
Dennis your son who you haven't spoken
to in five years called the other night
and you answered the phone and he heard
that you were drunk so he hung up and
Dennis would go hey life in the big city
and she'd go well your daughter just had
a baby and she doesn't really want you
near the kid and he'd go hey life in the
big city and he would sit there and just
drink wine and then he's also gone I
don't know why I said this he'd walk
around and he'd go wheeze B's Goods I
don't know what that was I don't know if
that's racist I don't know what it was
but he would just walk around the house
go wheeze B's Goods and drink a Burger
King plastic cup full of wine with ice
in it and smoked Marlboro Reds and look
at the fire and we would all smoke
inside this was a great this is a great
if you're hearing this now and you're
not nostalgic about the old world if
you're not nostalgic about ashing in a
fireplace and eating a beautiful big
baked clam and then asking that when
it's done I don't know what to tell you
I don't know what kind of life you had
how are you surrounded with that was so
great Dennis was
a psychopath you know but even my mother
loved and every conversation was tragic
Dennis is Dennis's sister wrote bad
checks okay sister-in-law sister-in-law
she wrote bad checks she was in the
newspaper and everything she defrauded a
guy out of his gas station and this was
a friend of my mother and Dennis she was
the bookkeeper for his gas station
completely defaulted him out of it the
guy ended up losing his whole gas
station service station everything and
um this lady went to jail they would
talk about her that was a big topic of
discussion they took about bankruptcies
people who were just [ __ ] boats you
know fights Dennis had a million fight
stories and it cracked him over the head
cracked him over the head and then this
was just a fun guy so Dennis when my
mother was screaming at us he just
opened two he goes hey patty will you
shut the [ __ ] up
it's just acid God you'd ruin anybody's
trip and he shut his door he's just an
unlikely ally they're just on acid it's
7:00 a.m. and your 15 year old son and
his best friend are just rolling on acid
and you're [ __ ] with him leave him
alone and my mother I think just went in
a room and shut her door but that was a
time when I look back and I'm like
because there's been a lot of times that
have been rough including the one now
he's sober but I look back at some of
that [ __ ] and I'm like yeah that was cuz
the mortgage [ __ ] it's all make sense do
you be doing coke with a bunch of
lunatics and you guys should be doing
drugs and everybody would be spending
money they don't have and I bought this
dumb house when I was 22 that all makes
that's kind of logical in in in the
[ __ ] climate but when I look back
eighth grade having some of the the
bigger drug dealers in my town
live in my actual house and and having
people say like well I got to go to 269
Madison and pick something up but I'd be
like hey can I get a ride no like you're
going there and I'm like oh I live there
I live there yeah I'm going there I'm
mom I'm going home so is there any way
that I can hop in there with you didn't
you fake that you got kidnapped or
something we this is a great story my
friend's sister was [ __ ] and her
name is Denise this is my friend Shay
and I she's doing great now she's not
[ __ ] we called it donk because do
you remember Tekken we used to love
playing Tekken wasn't there a clown in
it named doink
am I wrong I think so we called it doink
because she was uh she was slow
slower am I wrong on this I think it was
a clown named doink or maybe I don't
maybe it wasn't Tekken we loved playing
Tekken getting high eating barbecue
chicken pizza
chunky lactaid and playing Tekken these
are the stories these are the hot cool
stories of my drug addict childhood I
love them people have liked
it's like when I hear about when I go
through like the like some people really
on drugs just like [ __ ] hot people and
go to orgies and it's like how do you
people stop how do you stop if you just
do a coke and [ __ ] everyone in my act
with me it's like I was eatin BBQ
chicken pizza drinking lactaid playing
Tekken yeah that ran its course
I grew out of that well we called it
donk I don't know why she was slow we
slept over her house one night and we
said it would be really funny to put a
fake ransom note in the house and go
around the block
cuz even she isn't dumb enough to think
that we actually got kidnapped well we
did this and we put the ransom note I've
got what it's sad we kidnapped the boy
it was so dumb we made it dumber we
kidnapped the boys we want like three
you know we just wrote we want we didn't
even it wasn't wasn't even a dominant
denomination of money which is here as
your as your Zuzu's is this [ __ ] goes
back sees two note and calls the cops
cuz we smoked a weed in the park now
we're now we're terrified were in the
bushes hi
she's got a cop car outside of the house
we're like this the cops are like we
hear we heard later on they were laughed
in her face they're like this isn't
sweetie this isn't so the cops like
leave we finally go back to the house
she's crying she opens the doors because
it's not funny it's not funny
barb calls us Denis goes your mother's
on the phone right now
it was a funniest thing I've ever heard
of my life cuz we're bracing for like
we're bracing for like a beating like
verbally and then eventually physically
and I and Shay as a phone and I'm
listening yeah and barbash goes boys
listen Denis is [ __ ] she goes just
don't [ __ ] with her anymore
just go to bed and ding I'll get you in
the morning but she wasn't even mad
which was just it was so fun but it was
like that was a wheat I was a [ __ ] up
time but there was also like you know
you look back in your like people number
one had a lot more fucked-up situation
people who were molested people were
abused
I was neglected I think you know I would
have neglected me to vote to be honest I
kind of don't blame them at that point
you know but that was a time where I'm
like I could have spiraled crazy like I
had a friend that just died a kid that I
knew I'm doing a joke now bettors go
fund me on stage which is very funny but
he was a good kid and he just C got
involved with heroin man I thank God I
never got into that [ __ ] cuz that would
have been the end I think that would
have been the end I think if I'd ever
gotten involved in heroin or I don't
think I would have is it always hard to
make it out hard to make it out very
tough to make it out you know I from an
Irish Catholic family a lot of people
drank a lot of people did things I
shouldn't have done drug wise but it's
tough when the people you know the kid
that I knew
died of you know heroin they got
involved with that [ __ ] I got out of it
before that stuff started to you know I
I never saw it I was never rounded I
never heard about it I heard about crack
you know we were on coke all the time a
lot of other [ __ ] you know pills and
stuff but never heroin and thank thank
God because now you know you have kids
doing heroin at my age I would have been
one of those kids probably I would have
been one of those cuz I was one of those
kids just wasn't around it wasn't a
thing but it's a really a death sentence
if you get into it it's very [ __ ]
tough and you know I went to an
inpatient rehab and I went to an
outpatient rehab I went to an inpatient
rehab when I was 25 right before I
started comedy right as it was starting
Comi maybe a few months after I started
comedy actually and then I went to an
outpatient rehab when I was in eighth
grade which was fake yeah just go to
Garden City and you meet new drug
connections you sit there with a bunch
of kids you know go to group you share
yeah it's like you know my parents suck
and I just sometimes I just you know
they don't even understand me and I
those things don't do anything but then
I went the impatiens when I was 25 and
then out of [ __ ] you up because that
that and I didn't go to like one of
these you know rehabs you like rich
people go to like promises in the
Hamptons
you know I'm promises in Malibu not in
Hamptons you know where you ride horses
and and it's just you and a bunch of
celebrities riding horses and you live
in a beachfront villa and you hear all
about how great you are and how much you
know I went to a place called a Long
Island Center for recovery when I was 25
there was just meth heads they would
bang on your door at 7:00 a.m. ago it's
[ __ ] shorts and you have to like
serve breakfast and I remember like it
was just a [ __ ]
[Music]
'we didn't show her me i was gonna say
it was a wake-up call but not really it
did it did like eventually it absolutely
did but it wasn't the moment but it was
it was a [ __ ] wake-up call i think ol
rehab should be like that i'm against
all these cushy nice rehabs and now all
these sober houses or a big scam and i
hear about these things like i hear
about people these sober houses which
are homes where you know you have
somebody that she's basically being a
babysitter when you get out of a 28-day
program you have to go live in this
group home and you have a curfew and you
know to do certain things you have to
try to get work or whatever and you have
to go to group meetings and then the
people that run these places are often
you know addiction counselors they have
some certification but some of them are
like ex-addicts you know you ask them
you like I'm running a sober house like
what'd you do last year home invasions
you know it's like that's the way that
business works like yeah I was just
putting guns and elderly people's mouths
for money but now I run the sober house
and I'm gonna help you you're like okay
great
but a lot of them now we're just trying
to put people in beds and just to get
money cuz the rich will pay ridiculous
amounts of money to show me their kids
up you know when I checked into rehab I
barely had insurance I didn't show up
drunk enough to get approved for a full
28 days I got approved for like seven
days okay and that's what happens you
insurance is always looking for a way to
not pay and if you don't show up like
fully [ __ ] up they just go you don't
need this literally but if you're rich
private insurance will just pay for the
whole thing so and I used to do rehab
shows and I'd be like is everyone you
all know what it was you know you'll
know that the intake counselors face
when your insurance wasn't going through
like it would just they would start
switching all their you know they used
to be like as you were as they thought
your insurance was gonna cover the whole
thing they're like we're a family
anything you need and then when your
insurance is like doesn't go through
they're like you're gonna be fine
you're okay she's get back out there kid
we don't have any secrets here you
should go to God meet God go with God
you need God you don't need us it's like
oh yeah what am i insurance come back
bad they're like yeah sorry there's
about five grand a day for our program
God's free go get him go find him but
it's a big business now and might want
my guy I know in New York his girlfriend
is a sober companion which rich people
will just pay someone off in an
ex-addict to just sit next you want a
plane so you don't get loaded they'll
buy your first-class ticket
sit right next to that room they were
there rich son daughter some of them are
older people addicts and the sober
companion just babysits them and has to
tell people if they [ __ ] up you know
they'll go to parties with them I mean
imagine that this is my companion my
parents have a cats when you know you
have money you know you know my parents
uh this is a Mary you know my parents
pay her to babysit me I'm 28 and Mary
just flies out here to the hand is with
me and make sure I don't drink a bathtub
full of Rosie and [ __ ] myself like I did
last summer because my parent that
didn't really look too good during my
father's merger during the corporate
merger it didn't look good that I was
throwing up blood at the American Hotel
in Sag Harbor that wasn't really that
was like that was not a good look
so we now have a sober companion to
alert my parents if I do anything wrong
so much look at a glass of chardonnay my
my sober companion wolf you know that's
what it is man rehabs a big business and
if like if anybody in this audience is
struggling with addiction whether it's
booze whether it's pills
whether it's whatever it is the only
thing I could say you know is is really
keep using drugs because as a sober
person I'll be perfectly honest huh
you know yeah it's fine no I'm kidding
get help obviously don't you know how
long have we done here well we started
at 3 a.m. yeah what times now we've done
an hour and nine minutes
oh god we're gonna wrap this up this
will be the podcast that we put out um
when's Gavin come out Sunday yeah Gavin
will come out Sunday and and this will
be our next podcast mm-hmm which will
come out when this will come out the so
this is gonna come out the 29th or the
30th yeah well then we have an
announcement to make
- oh yeah we have an announcement yeah
um after I guess three years with Cass
digital and I love all those guys I love
Lewis I love Ralph I love everybody um
we are leaving
I'm going we're going independent we're
gonna do a lot of different stuff with
the show we don't know what we're gonna
do we're you're gonna get a podcast
every week you're probably gonna get -
there'll be a patreon if you want to
join and hop on and get extra stuff if
you want to get the longer versions of
some of the desk videos we do we're
doing a lot more content that's not just
podcasting but we're going that route
and there'll be more details about that
to come it's not it's nothing
contentious like I love gas there's
really love those guys just makes more
sense right now to be independent
because we don't know what we're gonna
do with this we don't know what this
will become we don't know if this is
gonna become multiple days a week you
know live-streaming to YouTube that's
kind of with the direction we think
we're going
- bring it on guests through in solo
episodes being all over the place trying
to bring those desk videos and bring you
more of those and more of that stuff
longer form stuff really funny [ __ ] you
know when I started this business I
thought that if I was funny the people
in the industry of comedy would care
that is not seemingly going to be the
situation they're not bad people they've
cared to an extent I've done some cool
things some specials and stuff we shot a
pilot I'm not like a bitter person but
that stuff we want to do the kind of
comedy that we want to do in the [ __ ]
that we want to make we're never gonna
get approval to do the [ __ ] we want to
do we just shot a video today that when
it comes out you book Jesus we're never
gonna be able to do that [ __ ] I don't
think we're ever gonna be able to do it
on Comedy Central I don't think we're
ever gonna be able to do it on network
TV I know we won't be able to do it on
network TV I don't know that we'll be
able to do it on cable TV and I don't
know that anybody at a big streaming
service is ever gonna write us a check
to do the comedy that we want to do
that's funny
in the way that we want to be funny but
that being said we will have a way for
you guys to support that that we will
just keep doing it regardless we want to
make people laugh and I just I I have
less faith now in I think there are so
many opportunities to just go it on your
own I have less faith in the business
coming to us unless we've built
something that's really truly undeniable
a self-sustaining thing and then people
in this business tend to come over and
want to buy it or take it or you know
whatever but until you're at that point
is very hard to get to that point when
everything you want to do is I mean
imagine if we submitted the Megan McCain
video to like a network
to get notes I mean imagine that imagine
like some somebody sitting there with a
script going okay so this line the only
one the only one you want to [ __ ] is
daddy I'll [ __ ] his corpse I'll [ __ ] his
corpse um it is is there a way to maybe
say that without saying it is there wita
maybe maybe less is more like maybe we
could hint I mean it would slow us down
we turn these videos that quickly it
would slow you down you don't need those
guys anymore
it's still nice to have them but you
don't need them so we're we're going we
don't know but we do know we're gonna be
independent we're gonna rebrand the show
it's not gonna be Tim Dylan's going to
hell it'll be just probably the Tim
Dylan show and we're gonna just it's
gonna be on the porch it's gonna be
[ __ ] balls out crazy when nobody
we're not waiting for anybody in the
business to hand us a bunch of money to
do this we're gonna find a way to do it
with the money that we have we're gonna
find a way to make [ __ ] that's funny and
cool that's kind of it you know there'll
be a time to give a better pitch but
most important thing whether you end up
subscribing to the patreon or given
money or doing whatever if you enjoy the
show if you like those videos that we do
share them retweet them put them on
Instagram get to get them out there
that's the most important thing to me
some people don't have the money to
contribute or whatever that's fine but
if you just keep putting that [ __ ] out
there keep telling friends about the
show keep telling other people that you
like it
that I think is the most important thing
to us because that's it we're in the era
now where if you want a certain type of
comedy you're gonna have to go and find
it it's not gonna be on SNL it's not
gonna happen it's not gonna be even
though you know alternate Ino is very
funny the pilot on Comedy Central
they're still really good [ __ ] being
made
you just can't wait for that I'm not
saying that it can't be made again or
that those guys won't end up making good
[ __ ] but you you can't wait for that
because if you wait for it you'd be
homeless and that's it you just gotta
take the bull by the horns and do it so
this will be coming up to 30th we're
gonna do another episode because we have
that Wix call and it's gonna be our last
episode with gasps it'll be a call an
episode come out mid-july with the
people that did the wig sponsors you
can't do it anymore don't do it now if
you did it you did it we're gonna get
you a number call in picture product
it'll be fun and then you know around
mid-july we're gonna just rebrand and
you guys will still be subscribed it'll
just you know change over and it'll be
the same it'll be you know the same show
that you've been listening to which is a
different name and there'll be some
there'll be some options if you want
more we'll have those options too and
we're gonna really start turning out
more content more videos more things
like that so thank you for listening
please continue to listen and you know
if you know a company that would want to
advertise on this show or if you own a
company that you want to destroy and you
think a really good way to do that and a
hilarious way to do that would be to
allow me to be kind of your spokesperson
I will step into those shoes and I will
run that baby into the ground thank you